ce diamants scintillants dans la nuit
méditerranéenne c'est le stade louis ii
de monaco
il est devenu aujourd'hui le symbole de
tous les tourments qui ébranle la
principauté samedi 1er décembre le club
de football de monaco reçoit montpellier
l'équipe va mal elle est avant dernière
du championnat de france
et comme si cela ne suffisait pas son
président est empêtré dans une affaire
qui n'a rien à voir avec le football
soupçonné d'avoir corrompu les plus
hautes autorités monégasques
le milliardaire russe dmitri rybolovlev
vient d'être inculpé les supporters
défendent leur président toujours
innocent c'est le même qui a beaucoup
apporté
on n'a pas de jugement moral apporté un
présomption d'innocence
ce soir l'as monaco perdre de busan le
nouvel entraîneur thierry henry est
dépité
[Musique]
dans les tribunes dimitri rybolovlev est
absent seul son représentant vadim
vasilyev assiste à la défaite
juste dessous la loge du principe id
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus tôt nous avions filmé la famille
princière exultant aux exploits de son
club à l'époque le souverain affiché
publiquement sa complicité avec le
milliardaire russe
aujourd'hui l'heure n'est plus à la fête
le rocher est secoué par le plus gros
scandale de son histoire
en 2006 la principauté s'était promise
d'être exemplaire lors de son
intronisation albert ii avait proclamé
vouloir placer son règne sous le signe
de la bonne gouvernance
j'entends cependant que l'éthique soit
toujours en toile de fond du
comportement des autorités monégasques
l'éthique ne se divise pas argent des
vertus doivent se conjuguer en
permanence le beau principe qui vole en
éclats en 2017
des révélations éclabousse le rocher et
bouscule les plus hautes personnalités
monégasques
en quelques mois la principauté voit
partir son directeur des services
judiciaires
philippe narmino l'équivalent du
ministre de la justice
son procureur général jean pierre dreno
un magistrat français est muté à aix en
provence
plusieurs enquêtes sont ouvertes dans le
viseur un ancien préfet des policiers un
commissaire principal
[Musique]
dans la minuscule principauté
c'est un tremblement de terre au coeur
de la faire le milliardaire russe
propriétaire de l'as monaco
dmitri rybolovlev médias yachts voitures
de luxe
grand hôtel
ce confetti de deux kilomètres carrés de
côte d'azur est la plus grande
concentration de milliardaires sur la
planète
un décor de rêve pour une histoire qui
commence par un coup tordu
nous sommes en février 2015
il vous viviez et suisse et marchand
d'art
il a rendez vous avec le richissime
homme d'affaires russe qui est aussi
collectionneur d'oeuvres d'art en dix
ans yves ouviers lui a vendu des toiles
de maîtres et des sculptures pour 2
milliards d'euros
parmi elles le célèbre salvatore mundi
de léonard de vinci revendu depuis c'est
aujourd'hui le tableau le plus cher du
monde
[Musique]
j'ai rendez-vous autre monsieur rigolo
av je souhaite le voir
ce dernier a insisté pour me raconter
absolument à monaco à ce moment là il me
doit environ 50 millions d'euros
je sais que le rendez vous est même
difficile parce que quand vous réclamer
de l'argent un oligarches milliardaire
et qui veut pas vous payer ça va pas
être facile donc j'ai mes petites notes
avec moi je les relis et je me concentre
coural pour l'affronter lors des rendez
ce que le marchand d'art ignore c'est
que le russe a porté plainte contre lui
à monaco
il l'accuse de lui avoir vendu les
tableaux beaucoup trop cher dimitri
rybolovlev estime l'escroquerie à un
milliard d'euros
le chauffeur dit bouvier le conduire en
plein centre-ville à la belle époque un
des immeubles les plus cossus de monaco
mais ce rendez vous chez dimitri
rybolovlev va mal tourner
ou un attroupement de personnes au fond
moi je marche de 6 le mans vers eux en
disant vous êtes les gardes du corps
d'oswald j rendez vous au dernier étage
à 10h personnes surpris il me sort la
carte de police et lâchant cercle homo
mais les mots note vieux s'y mettent les
sharks je n'écarte toujours là sur les
mots not pourquoi qu'on voit que les
monos tente là et la voiture on est à
monaco en à monaco le marchand d'art et
placé en garde à vue dans les locaux de
la police pendant trois jours
mise en examen pour escroquerie
il est libéré contre le versement d'une
caution de 7 millions d'euros
nous interrogeons son avocat monégasque
selon lui le marchand d'art serait tombé
dans un piège
ce que l'oligarque russe a toujours
démenti monsieur rybolovlev lui donne
rendez vous à monaco
officiellement pour parler de leurs
affaires et en réalité on allait tendre
ce qu'on appelle un traquenard
judiciaire c'est-à-dire tout mettre en
place par une sorte de synergie entre
les policiers chargés de l'enquêté
l'avocate de dimitri et volvo leif et et
dimitri lui-même rybolovlev de manière à
le faire venir pour le piéger le soupçon
le d'outines et ce moment là et le doute
c'est quoi passer tout simplement que si
on veut le faire à monaco vous le faire
venir à monaco c'est qu'on pense que là
on a des appuis qu'on n'aurait pas
ailleurs dimitri rybolovlev et résident
monégasque
c'est une figure du rocher il vit dans
ce penthouse de 2000 mètres carrés face
à la mer
prix d'achat 240 millions d'euros sa
terrasse donne sur le port et le palais
princier
il a même installé une mini salle de
marché dans une pièce attenante à son
salon
[Musique]
en 2011 il s'est aussi offert le club de
football de monaco
l'asm dont le premier supporters est le
prince albert ii en 2017
il décroche le titre de champion de
france
[Applaudissements]
en option les halls tape juste les
et dans son affrontement avec le
marchand d'art le milliardaire russe a
gagné la première manche mais l' enquête
va se retourner contre lui à cause de sa
plus proche collaboratrice détiennent à
beersheba
elle est ukrainienne elle a 34 ans et
vit entre la suisse et monaco
elle est là vocable de dimitri
rybolovlev et comme le milliardaire ne
parle que le russe elle tient aussi le
rôle d'interprète et d'intermédiaires le
juge d'instruction chargé de l'enquêté
bouvier rybolovlev s'appelle edward
levraud il saisit le téléphone portable
de l'avocate et en extrait des milliers
de sms qu'elle croyait avoir effacé le
juge procède à une expertise et cette
expertise met à jour un certain nombre
de messages téléphoniques dont certains
sont très compromettants et établisse
une collusion entre certains policiers
certains membres du gouvernement et
dmitri rybolovlev par l'intermédiaire de
son avocate
en première ligne le ministre de la
justice de monaco
philippe narmino
philippe narmino est une des plus hautes
personnalités du rocher en tant que
ministre il ne rencontre co princes il
dirige la croix rouge monégasque une
institution locale
on le voit ici avec sa femme christine
le juge s'interroge le ministre de la
justice aurait t'il préparer
l'arrestation du marchand d'art avec
dimitri rybolovlev un week end en suisse
intrigue le magistrat il a lieu quelques
jours à peine avant l'arrestation du
bouvier le 25 février 2015
le milliardaire russe invite philippe
narmino et sa femme à une soirée à
gstaad en suisse
ils vont faire le trajet à bord de son
hélicoptère
le voyage est décrit dans cet échange de
sms entre l'avocate et la femme du
ministre
bonsoir christine comme promis voici
l'invitation à la fête de samedi
on se voit demain à l'héliport tetyana
merci tetyana ok pour 15 heures avec du
porc à demain baiser christina
monaco gstaad 300 km une heure de vol
sur ce document les enquêteurs ont
estimé le coût de ce voyage offert au
ministre et à sa femme
trente sept mille euros
[Musique]
au coeur des alpes jeter la station la
plus huppée de suisse avec ses palaces
prestigieux ses boutiques de luxe et ses
chalets de stars ici le chalet jade de
johnny hallyday là le chalet du
réalisateur roman polanski
[Musique]
nous avons rendez vous avec sylvain
besson
journaliste au quotidien suisse le temps
alors là on va arriver on pas là ce dock
stade
il a été au courant très tôt de la
présence du ministre monégasque dans une
soirée huppée de la station ocstat
palace je vais déjeuner chez un banquier
qui me dit en fait sous cette affaire
bouvier il ya vraiment un coup pourri
c'est que le directeur des services
judiciaires de monaco juste avant
l'arrestation du bouvier et bien la
rencontre et dimitri rybolovlev ça s'est
passé au palace de gstaad
le milliardaire et le ministre passe la
soirée dans cet hôtel
un événement mondain organisé tous les
ans par un grand joaillier suisse
nous avons retrouvé des images de ces
fêtes
jet set
en soirée c'est festive avec des bijoux
des jolies femmes du champagne etc
on le sait grâce à des gens qui étaient
à la soirée qui connaissent monaco et
donc qu'ils ont tout de suite reconnu
philippe narmino et qui ont tout de
suite compris qu'il y avait un lien on
va dire suspects entre philippe narmino
et dmitri rybolovlev ces gens là ont
discuté entre eux se sont isolés étaient
ensemble finalement ils parlaient
ensemble c'est pas juste qu'ils se sont
croisés qui sont fait rouler sans se
parler
non ils étaient ensemble le journaliste
suisse révèle la rencontre dans son
quotidien
[Musique]
dès le lendemain philippe narmino dément
dans la presse monégasque toute
connivence avec le milliardaire
ce n'était pas du tout un dîner privé il
n'y a pas il ne peut y avoir de rapport
entre ma présence là bas et cette
affaire le juge se demande aujourd'hui
si les deux hommes se sont concertés
pour préparer l'arrestation d' yves
bouvier
d'autant qu'un autre élément vient
renforcer cette hypothèse
en réalité le couple narmino a passé le
week end entier dans le chalet de
dimitri rybolovlev en témoigne ce sms de
l'épousé du ministre de la justice
merci encore cher tetyana pour cette
agréable week-end en ta compagnie
[Musique]
remercie chaleureusement dimitri de
notre part pour son hospitalité sans
faille et renouvelle lui nos amitiés et
nos félicitations pour la beauté de sa
résidence jeta d'oise
bonne soirée et à bientôt philippe et
christine la réponse de l'avocat du
milliardaire russe est quasi instantané
merci beaucoup à vous c'était un grand
plaisir de passer ce week end avec vous
et ce qui ensemble
je ne manquerai pas de transmettre votre
message à dimitri qui était ravi de vous
recevoir chez lui
bonne soirée
je vous embrasse tetiana
et là on voit très bien la partie de
dimitri rybolovlev le week end a eu lieu
ici
le russe est propriétaire d'un ensemble
de trois chalets relié sous terre par un
immense spa valeur de la propriété 160
millions d'euros
être invité ici c'est vraiment un
privilège rare parce que dmitri
rybolovlev n'est pas décrit comme
quelqu'un d'extrêmement chaleureux ni de
très très mondain pour philippe narmino
d'être invité dans ces chalets c'est une
marque de confiance et de proximité
voire d'amitié qui est vraiment très
forte
de retour à monaco nous avons demandé à
dimitri rybolovlev une interview sur ses
relations avec le ministre de la justice
monégasque
pas de réponse
mais devant le tribunal
pascal fils former des alliances est
génial
nous tombons par hasard sur son avocat
hervé temime
un ténor du barreau parisien les gens
disent c'est chanter c'est gentil rien à
vous dire vous verrez la justice et le
droit triomphe avait rassuré on l'espère
tous
la rencontre tourne court
[Musique]
mais quelques semaines après ce refus
surprise l'avocat nous appelle il veut
nous parler
il nous reçoit dans son cabinet parisien
est ce que vous trouvez normal qu'un
mythe de la justice passe des vacances
avec l'une des parties dans une affaire
il n'a pas passé de vacances 6 face aux
affaires il a milité dans son chalet où
il était dans son chalet pas pendant des
vacances mais cela est bien cinq jeux
enfin je crois qu'un d'écouter ce qui
est un fait c'est que à aucun moment ce
cet événement n'a eu la moindre
conséquence sur le traitement judiciaire
de la sphère dont vous parlez à aucun
moment lors est fera partie des
investigations et méritera vous avez
tout à fait raison des questions et des
réponses en france le miz la justice
passe récent week-end la marine on me
semblerait normal donc ça ne me
semblerait absolument pas normal mais on
est tous d'accord là dessus on enfonce
des portes ouvertes
la question n'est pas de savoir c'est
normal la question de savoir si c'est
illégal
or pour que ce soit illégale et que ce
ne soit pas un simple manquements
déontologiques
encore faut-il que ça a eu une influence
sur le traitement de la procédure et je
vous dis que ce n'est pas le cas le 14
septembre 2017
philippe narmino publie un communiqué il
annonce son départ
j'ai pris la décision de renoncer à la
poursuite de mes fonctions en demandant
à faire valoir mes droits à la retraite
anticipée
[Musique]
le juge d'instruction chargé de la faire
place philippe narmino en garde à vue et
lance des perquisitions tous azimuts
dans ses bureaux à son domicile et sur
ses comptes bancaires à monaco en ce
mois de septembre 2010 est en apparence
tout va bien chaque jour à 11h50 pile la
relève de la garde suit un cérémonial
immuable
[Musique]
mais derrière les murs du palais
princier souffle désormais un petit vent
de panique
paris-match titre sur le scandale les
soupçons touche le coeur du pouvoir dans
l'urgence le prince nomme un remplaçant
à philippe narmino laurent ans et demi
le nouveau ministre de la justice
accepte de nous rencontrer
il joue la simplicité mais vous vous
avez une voiture de fonction
ah non aucun gouvernement voiture de
fonction
aucun membre du gouvernement l'organisme
a non plus n'a de chopper le 5-1 chopper
c'est le ministre d'état jean beauchesne
gouvernement donc voilà ça fait une
économie en termes de dépenses publiques
y pense monaco est un tout petit pays la
maison d'arrêt en dessous un petit pays
comme les autres avec ses contraintes
budgétaires ses institutions et sa
prison c'est très sécurisé le directeur
nous fait la visite
ces messieurs
quartier de la voyez le quartier de
détention femme est là donc il ya un an
permanente en permanence une
surveillante ce qui est là j'aurai une
haie
c'est
les chalets on va vous montrer la vue
sur la mer n'est pas terrible c'est une
échappée de mer il y a une trentaine de
cellules comme celle ci avec télévision
et vue sur la mer
elles sont rarement toutes occupées est
plutôt par des petits délinquants selon
le ministre de la justice
on accorde un peu attirés aussi la
convoitise de personnes malhonnêtes et
de personnes qui pensent que nonobstant
toutes les mesures télésurveillance et
de tout ça ils pourront réussir à voler
à faire le casse du siècle ou ne serait
ce qu'à aller dans une discothèque
expliquer quelque chose à quelqu'un qui
fait pas attention donc
donc c'est un peu ça je dirais autres
fonds de commerce
si le plus m'exprimer ainsi
de retour à son bureau nous
l'interrogeons sur le cac narmino moi je
n'entends pas me prononcer sur le départ
de mon prédécesseur ni les circonstances
qui l'ont amené à considérer devoir
faire valoir ses droits à la retraite
il a fait j'ai été choisi pour lui pour
lui succéder
c'est la seule chose que je retiens
l'image de la justice de la principauté
at elle souffert de cette démission sont
son blason elle est éclaboussée elle est
éclaboussé par cette affaire parce que
si vous voulez c'est dans la presse etc
et quand ça concerne monaco évidemment
on en fait si aujourd'hui me permettre
des gorges chaudes la sphère va suivre
son cours et moi si vous voulez je je je
souhaite vraiment que tous et toutes ces
instructions aboutisse pour qu'on fasse
toute la vérité sur cette affaire
au cours de nos investigations nous
sommes entrés en contact avec un homme
qui prétend en savoir beaucoup sur
philippe narmino il s'appelle robert
eringer
il vit en californie à santa barbara
il assure avoir été l'espion du prince
albert ii et avoir enquêté sur philippe
narmino à sa demande
ancien journaliste pour la presse à
scandale britannique robert eringer
rencontre le prince albert ii au début
des années 2000 et lui propose de monter
un service de renseignements personnels
il parle pour la première fois
voici la carte que lui délivre le palais
princier
il est l'agent 001 et touche un salaire
de 30 mille euros par mois n'ont volé au
stade rien personne ne leur enseigne est
sur quoi que ce soit on a donc décidé
que je serai celui qui assumerait sur
route
il m'a embauchée pour travailler
directement pour lui as en tant qu agent
de renseignement vous avez eu pour
mission d'enquêter sur monsieur narmino
à cette époque aussi bien sûr j'ai
enquêté et je lui ai remis un rapport
écrit ce rapport confidentiel
le voici son objet philippe narmino le
détective affirme l'avoir remis au
prince selon l'américain philippe
narmino aurait utilisé sa position de
vice président de la croix rouge
monégasque pour toucher des commissions
sur les dons à l'association oeuvre
d'art bijoux immobilier etc
disons par exemple que vous faites don
d'un appartement à la croix rouge
monégasque d'une valeur d'un million
d'euros narmino à un ami il dirige une
société du nom d'âgés prime on lui
confie l'appartement pour une évaluation
du riz qui lui prend 45 minutes il
reçoit pour cent de la valeur
cinquante mille euros pour 45 minutes de
travail de ses salariés
ils ont partagé j'imagine je ne connais
pas leurs arrangements mais nous sommes
certains de l'existence de ce système
parce que ce sont les policiers qui
m'ont informé de ce montage
les policiers ne savaient ils me l'ont
dit mais il n'était pas autorisé avertir
directement albert moi je pouvais le
dire à albert
le prince sera averti mme il ne tiendra
pas compte des alertes de son rapport
albert sénat mais il n'a tué personne je
me trompe c'est normal ça a toujours été
comme ça à monaco
c'est comme ça qu'on fait alors qu'est
ce qu'il avait mais l'a nommé narmino
ministre de la justice philippe narmino
ne sera jamais inquiété pour l'histoire
de la croix rouge
nous l'avons sollicité pour une
interview il ne nous a pas répondu
longue de choc va se propager sur le
rocher et toucher une autre figure de la
justice monégasque en 2015
le procureur général de monaco s'appelle
jean pierre dreno
le juge s'interroge at il favorisé le
clan rybolovlev ce haut magistrat été
nommé à monaco en 2011
il est français c'est une particularité
de la principauté de monaco
la france exerce un droit de regard sur
le choix de ses fonctionnaires
elle lui fournit la plupart de ces
magistrats policiers services
administratifs ils sont nommés par le
prince
sur proposition du gouvernement français
détaché pour trois ans renouvelable une
fois
nous avons retrouvé cette vidéo sur le
site du ministère de la justice français
peu après sa nomination jean pierre
dreno affirme l'indépendance du
magistrat français détaché à l'égard du
prince de monaco
j'ai prêté serment lors de ma prise de
fonction devant le prince albert ii
depuis je n'ai aucune relation directe
avec avec le prince a justice est rendue
au nom du prince mais en totale
indépendance
c'est donc en toute indépendance que le
procureur général dreno aurait dû
superviser l'enquète bouvier rybolovlev
nous sommes en février 2015
arrêté le marchand d'art est en garde à
vue la justice monégasque doit se
prononcer sur une éventuelle mise en
détention provisoire par écrit
jean pierre dreno demande
l'incarcération
requerront qu'il plaise à monsieur le
juge d'instruction de placer yves
bouvier en détention provisoire
[Musique]
sévère avec yves bouvier le procureur ce
serait montrer plus coopératifs avec le
camp rybolovlev encore une histoire de
téléphone
l'avocate du milliardaire voulait
enregistrer un témoin à son insu le
magistral aurait conseillé
c'est ce que tetyana beersheba déclare
aux policiers cet enregistrement avait
été effectué avec le conseil juridique
du procureur général d'hwr et non à
cause de cet enregistrement
l'avocate et le milliardaire sont mises
en examen pour atteinte à la vie privée
ils n'ont pas voulu répondre à nos
questions au téléphone jean pierre dreno
admet une conversation avec l'avocate
mais dément l'avoir conseiller oui être
berger la lie c'est monsieur dreno qui
m'a conseillé vers l'enregistrement
non pas du tout non non rien et 119 cas
non non non le déplorons c'est qu'elle a
un secret professionnel de manifestement
elle ne respecte pas il a lu
conversations professionnelles de la
beauté pure le les modes de preuve
possible l'oca cas le jeu lui en
remontrer par l'avocat du clan
rybolovlev reconnaît lui aussi qu'un tel
échange a pu avoir lieu
mais il en minimise la portée je veux
bien qu' il y ait des choses qui vous
étonne et qui étonne et que je ne valide
pas sur des liens entre tel ou tel cela
en revanche n'a rien à voir avec le
traitement judiciaire de cette affaire
depuis jean pierre dreno a été mise en
examen pour atteinte à la vie privée
pour le procureur cette mise en cause
tombe mal elle va faire remonter à la
surface
une affaire qui le poursuit depuis 2014
cette année là le magazine le point
révèle que le procureur de monaco a
acheté un appartement par
l'intermédiaire d'un certain herminio
giraud dit ce proche de silvio
berlusconi soupçonné d'avoir aidé
l'industriel italien à frauder le fisc
[Musique]
nous avons retrouvé la trace de cet
appartement en italie dans la petite
station balnéaire dos pédales et y à
40km de monaco
voici le logement en question l'endroit
ne paie pas de mine
le concierge nous le confirme le
magistrat et le businessman italien
aurait bien été en affaires et beaucoup
de fois et c'est à quel moment il a
acheté jamais à quel moment
oui et nous et gerdi vous les connaissez
[Musique]
au moment de l'achat le magistrat
savait-il à qui il avait affaire
d'après ce document la police monégasque
était informé que l'homme d'affaires
était poursuivi en italie pour
blanchiment de fraude fiscale
notification d'un acte judiciaire
signifiant sa mise en examen
et curieusement il est écrit un peu plus
loin ne pas enquêter en cas
d'interpellation
l'italien est il protégé par les
autorités monégasques le 6 juillet 2011
dans cet article paru dans un grand
journal italien il giorno le procureur
général de milan fustige la mauvaise
coopération de la justice de monaco sur
le cagire audi
on est franchement la limite du
raisonnable quand l'article paraît jean
pierre dreno nommé au printemps 2011 est
en fonction depuis trois mois
[Musique]
moi je m'étonne très honnêtement de la
proximité d'un camp on se dit cette
personne quand même a maille à partir
avec la justice italienne
on essaye de rester à 10 ans n'attendait
me suis moi tu découvert que steam en or
lui une procédure le concernant plus ou
moins l'étape qui est apprécié moi je
fais la connaissance d'un accusé ralenti
quand j'arrive sur sur mona porte à la
connaissance de tous répondu oui la mode
moi je les connais pas ah je ne connais
pas à supposer qu'il y ait plus
concernés par des procédures et amiens
après tout il m'a dit qu'il ne pas
n'était pas berlusconi qu'une jamais
rencontré il a toujours aujourd'hui
le businessman italien n'est plus
poursuivi par la justice de son pays
l'afer qui le concerne
est prescrite
[Musique]
herminio giraudi prospère il possède ce
restaurant renommé de monaco nous
tentons notre chance
mais aujourd'hui la tendance c'est
possible de le voir
[Musique]
notre hôte et est plutôt accueillants
l'homme est accompagnée de son gendre
nous les films ont à leur insu conter
une histoire comme quoi vendu un
appartement à procureur de monaco
monsieur dreno ça vous dit quelque chose
jean pierre dreno ouais voilà venu le
voir en quoi l'histoire comme vous
asseoir raisonnée
voilà ça mais vous connaissiez
personnellement et
quand on lui parle d'un éventuel échange
de bons procédés avec le procureur
il se met en colère jean pierre dreno le
reconnaît la sphère lui a coûté son
poste ne prend considère que je fais une
très mauvaise publicité on rochon à la
principauté ce que je comprends tout à
fait puisque on sous-entend que je dise
affaires douteuses et donc et tout mon
le frein le prince le monde jean pierre
dreno a depuis été muté à aix en
provence
le juge en charge de l'enquêté bouvier
rybolovlev continuent de fouiller dans
le passé du procureur
[Musique]
souvenez-vous du téléphone de tetyana
beersheba l'avocate de dimitri
rybolovlev et de ses nombreux sms avec
le ministre de la justice avec le
procureur général
le juge d'instruction découvre qu'elle
communique aussi avec un commissaire de
police
christophe haget et son adjoint le
magistrat se demande sont ils sortis des
clous
[Musique]
à monaco les agents sont réputée
intraitable avec les petites infractions
circulation stationnement vol et
escroquerie
mais certains semblent moins regardant
avec les riches résidents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les sms de thé tiennent à beersheba
décrivent une hiérarchie policière très
empressés au tour de dimitri ribot le
plein
[Musique]
deux jours avant l'arrestation du
marchand d'art l'avocate fait passer un
message du milliardaire russe auprès du
chef de la police judiciaire christophe
haget et de son adjoint il voulait aussi
vous parler en compte comme si on ne se
voit pas ce soir est-ce possible par
exemple vers 17h15 17h30
la réponse des policiers est quasi
immédiate vers 17h30
l'avocat dit bouvier a décortiqué ces
sms
il dénonce une police aux ordres apprend
par exemple que monsieur rybolovlev
président des réunions dans les locaux
de la sûreté publique qui sont relatifs
au dossier dans lequel il est opposé à
yves bouvier c'est absolument incroyable
comme situation
certains sms le montre dimitri
rybolovlev dr semble dicter l'agenda
serez vous au bureau aujourd'hui des
airs voudrait passer vous voir pour
faire le point et discuter de la suite
avant son départ demain de monaco pour
une semaine merci davance amitié tetiana
on se rend compte par exemple dans ce
sms que les policiers certains policiers
monégasques qui sont ceux chargés de
l'enquète travaille plus pour l'état il
travaille pour dmitri rybolovlev tout en
continuant à être payés par l'état au
fil des échanges
les relations sont de plus en plus
cordiales cher tetyana merci pour ce
moment à demain amitié christophe cher
christophe merci à vous pour votre temps
et d'avoir partagé avec moi vos
expériences exceptionnelles
cela m'a fait très plaisir de déjeuner
avec vous à demain amitié et iona
pour mieux comprendre les relations
entre le milliardaire russe et les
policiers
il faut aller au stade louis 2 le stade
de son club de football
[Musique]
à monaco les tribunes sont rarement
remplies
le club et surtout pour le milliardaire
une formidable machine à distribuer des
cadeaux
avant le scandale le prince était assidu
on le voit ici en février 2014 aux côtés
de son épouse de dmitri rybolovlev et de
son avocate
[Musique]
lors d'un match en mai dernier nous
avions pu filmer ses loges dans la
tribune d'honneur
sont les meilleures places avec les
célébrités locales comme le prince et sa
soeur stéphanie
ou encore national comme ici le
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
didier deschamps
beaucoup ne paient pas leur place le
club en offre des centaines
nous découvrons que les policiers en
bénéficient nous nous sommes procuré la
liste des invités réguliers des tribunes
d'honneur
en plus des invités du palais princier
de l'archevêché des employés des
ministères la sûreté publique la police
bénéficie de 49 invitation permanente
[Musique]
c'est faveur n'ont rien d'anecdotique
elles forment même une piste pour le
juge en charge de l'enquêté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons eu accès au témoignage d'un
ancien policier christian car pinelli
selon lui le commissaire christophe
haget fait bien partie des heureux
bénéficiaires car pinelli dénonce les
faveurs que faisait monsieur rybolovlev
à l'égard de certaines hautes
personnalités notamment du commissaire
âgées interrogé par le juge
le policier évalue le prix d'un tel
cadeau deux places en tribune d'honneur
avec accès au buffet avant et pendant le
match j'ai pu apprendre qu'ils étaient
d'une valeur de 7000 euros par an hors
taxes et par place
[Musique]
récapitulons alors qu'il est en charge
de l'enquêté bouvier rybolovlev le
commissaire âgées entretiennent une
relation presque amicales avec l'avocate
de dimitri rybolovlev ils bénéficient
aussi avec ses collègues d'invitation
régulière au match de foot est il encore
aujourd'hui aux commandes de l'enquète
il a refusé de nous répondre
nous interrogeons le ministre de la
justice je crois que aujourd moment nous
parlons les officiers de police
judiciaire qui sont dans cette dans
cette affaire ne sont plus ceux qui ont
été mises en cause
à l'église a été écartée pour l'instant
suspendu provisions non ils n'ont pas
été suspendues et je veux dire il ya
d'autres affaires qui les mobilisent
mais papa salle là c'est ce que c'est ce
que je pense
oui c'est ce que je sais
[Musique]
les loges du stade 2 monaco vont nous
livrer d'autres secrets
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur paul
masseron à peine retraité a été embauché
par le patron de l'as monaco
paul masseron quittera ses fonctions
pour prendre sa retraite son départ en
2015 est un petit évènement sur le
rocher
le cocktail est diffusée sur la chaîne
de télé locale monaco chanel compte
occasion michel roger est revenu sur le
brillant parcours de paul masseron en
rappelant qu'il a été le plus jeune
préfet de france en 1987
[Musique]
dix jours à peine après son départ à la
retraite
l'ancien ministre est embauché comme
conseiller du président de l'as monaco
dimitri rybolovlev à la clé un salaire
conséquent
voici son contrat de travail cinquante
mille euros par an qui viennent
s'ajouter à sa retraite de préfet et de
ministre de l'intérieur
il a refusé de répondre à nos questions
[Musique]
cette embauche serait un très mauvais
calcul selon un des conseillers de
dimitri rybolovlev david vigneault il
s'en offusque dans un sms à l'avocate t
tiennent à beersheba tetyana on en a pas
parlé mais l'histoire de ma seront est
extrêmement mauvaise pour dr bien sûr je
conseille que dr ne disent pas un mot
entre nous c'est vraiment incroyable à
monaco de ce genre d'arrangement soit
proposée par le ministre mais sur le
fond c'est une mauvaise opération
l'avocat du marchand d'art yves bouvier
s'interroge sur le rôle que j'aurai le
club dans la principauté
il s'agit de voir s'il ya ou pas à
monaco un système de corruption dont
l'asm serait le centre ou un des centres
et qui mettrait en cause un nombre qu'on
ne connaît pas de personnalités
officielles
[Musique]
des milliers de sms ressusciter des
centaines de documents et de témoignages
rassemblés la sphère bouvier rybolovlev
est le fruit du travail d'un juge
français détaché à monaco edwards le
gros son enquête a provoqué une onde de
choc en révélant des secrets
parmi les mieux gardés du rocher il a
pourtant failli être contraint de tout
abandonner
en février dernier le nouveau ministre
de la justice veut limiter à trois ans
non renouvelable le mandat des juges
détaché par la france l'état français
fournit la moitié des magistrats la
principauté
il a son mot à dire
selon la magistrate céline parisot à
paris les juges ont besoin de temps pour
mener les enquêtes à leur terme
raccourcir leur mandat c'est diminuer
leur pouvoir la france collabore quand
même complètement à la justice
monégasque puisque l envoi elle pourvoit
à la moitié à peu près des effectifs de
la magistrature on est bien obligé de
s'y intéresser et du coup est bien
obligé de se poser la question pourquoi
pourquoi les empêcher de faire leur
travail finalement l'idée derrière ça
c'est de dire ne venez pas vous
installer à l'as monaco finalement ne
venait pas trop mettre le nez dans nos
affaires que vous voyez derrière c'est
quoi c'est une censure bahia est
manifestement une volonté de porter
atteinte au bon travail de la justice
voilà ce qu'il ya derrière ça c'est très
clair pour les magistrats s'en servent
le fait de n'avoir que des mandats de
trois ans non renouvelable était une
forme de censure masqué sur des affaires
en cours alors qu'ils se faisaient alors
ça c'est certain c'est un procès
d'intention parce qu'il ya une rotation
normale des juges et même dans les
fameuses affaires en cours
eh bien il ya déjà eu des juges
d'instruction qui ont succédé à d'autres
juges d'instruction donc c'est une
pratique tout à fait normal c'est
peut-être le changement qui a suscité
cette réaction face à la fronde
le ministre de la justice a fini par
renoncer à cette mesure
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une responsabilité
de monsieur rybolovlev dans cette mise à
mal des institutions monégasques
il ya incontestablement un homme
semble-t-il qui a quand même eu un rôle
non négligeable en faveur de la
principauté je pense pas qu'on puisse
contester l'action de monsieur rigolo
l'aide notamment au sein du club de
football de l'as monaco
je regrette comme vous sans doute que
les institutions monégasques et a eu à
souffrir de mouvements quand même
très violent je ne crois pas que la
responsabilité de monsieur rybolovlev
puissent être engagées dans cette crise
institutionnelle
derrière les mises en cause et les
démissions leprince at il le pouvoir de
mettre de l'ordre dans la principauté
rappelez vous ses engagements de 2005 il
avait marqué les esprits
[Musique]
j'entends cependant que l'éthique soit
toujours en toile de fond du
comportement des autorités monégasques
treize ans plus tard après le départ
forcé de son ministre de la justice et
de son procureur général
son ancien agent secret 0,01 à des mots
très durs
je ne suis plus très précisément ce qui
se passe à monaco
je ne sais pas ce qu'il allait revenir
sur lequel j'ai une année ce prix pour
la donne est ce que je sais de l'aic je
suis par gwénaëlle c'est que rien n'a
changé même si le prince albert a promis
à ses sujets et au monde entier objecte
qu'il allait introduire une nouvelle
éthique à monaco vous avec tout le monde
d'accord
rien de tout cela n'est vraiment arrivé
en fin de compte il n'a jamais les
épaules offert quoi que ce soit contre
d'où sa rivale
[Musique]
nous avons sollicité son altesse
sérénissime le prince albert 2 pour une
interview
nous lui avons adressé un long mail sans
réponse nous étions alors au début de
l'été le 6 novembre dernier le juge
edward le broc a lancé un vaste coup de
filet effet interpellé neuf
protagonistes fait exceptionnel toute la
hiérarchie policière de monaco se
retrouve en garde à vue régis assauts
christophe haget
et frédéric fusari même traitement pour
l'ancien ministre de la justice et sa
famille
philippe narmino christine antoine
l'ancien préfet paul masseron n'y
échappe pas non plus jean pierre dreno
ancien procureur général avait été
inculpé dès juin dernier enfin le
milliardaire russe dmitri rybolovlev et
son avocate et yann à berchidda sont eux
aussi arrêtés ils passeront tous deux
jours dans les locaux de la police avant
d'être inculpé pour corruption trafic
d'influencé et violation du secret
professionnel puis remise en liberté
après cette série d'inculpations
le prince s'est finalement exprimé le 12
novembre devant plusieurs journalistes
de presse écrite dont mediapart
interrogé sur sa proximité avec
l'oligarque russe
il affirme je n'ai jamais passé
plusieurs jours d'affilée avec monsieur
rybolovlev c'était toujours ponctuel
l'année dernière quand on a fait une
croisière familiale dans les îles
grecques
on s'est arrêtés même pas une journée
sur son île
quant au sort du président de l'as
monaco le prince déclare si tout cela
est avéré
monsieur rigolo fleuve se retirera de
lui même avec ses déclarations
le prince albert prend ses distances
avec une affaire qui éclabousse son
règne
[Musique]